in den usa protestieren menschen gegen
korona maßnahmen zum teil schwer
bewaffnet einer der größten protesten
michigan stattgefunden
vor dem kapitol erklärt ein mann mit
schussweste und einem amerika wappen auf
der brust wofür er steht unter schock
ich möchte den leuten zeigen dass es
keinen grund gibt angst zu haben unsere
rechte auszuüben
wir leben in einem freien land der welt
und es ist unser recht das zu tun
hier draußen zu sein etwas das er machen
müssen damit wir unsere rechte nicht
verlieren den angaben von krankenhäusern
und ärzten glaubt er nicht
die meisten leute haben realisiert dass
die zahlen zur wird 19 etwas übertrieben
wurden wenn nicht sogar falsch
dargestellt
es wird dazu benutzt extrem strikte
regeln für die menschen festzulegen und
das ist verfassungswidrig
wenn es für einen politischen zweck
benutzt wird also politiker sterbende
menschen benutzen um mehr macht zu
bekommen müssen wir uns dagegen wehren
präsident donald trump unterstützt das
verhalten der protestierenden in den usa
sind bisher über 40.500 kroner
infizierte gestorben
ja und wir möchten jetzt zu meinem
kollegen herbert bauernebel schalten er
ist in michigan vor ort einem der
zentren der demonstrationen herbert
wiest dort die stimmung und worum geht
es den demonstranten so ganz konkret
es ist heute ruhig demonstrationen
angesagt
geplant sind weitere in den nächsten
tagen natürlich das alles kommt wirklich
spektakulären bilder niemand gesehen hat
in der vorwoche als mir vielleicht
50.000 menschen sogar hier protestiert
haben und natürlich hier auch eine
gruppe bewaffneter demonstranten
anhänger der sogenannten rätseln und man
sieht hier jetzt hier mainstream in
lenzing hinzu mir sieht man eigentlich
das problem
die straße ist völlig verwaist alle
geschäfte sind geschlossen viele
menschen haben die arbeit verloren und
gleichzeitig ist hier in lens in die
zahl der fälle nicht besonders hoch und
einige wenige sagen diese milizen
diese anhänger das übertrieben wurde
dass hier die reading zu krassen dass
die menschen ihre arbeit verlieren ihre
jobs und dass das in keinem verhältnis
stehen würde zu den aktuellen zahlen
deshalb demonstrieren sie auch und
natürlich viele nehmen ihre waffen mit
um zu demonstrieren dass sie die
verfassung so interpretieren dass wenn
eine regierung zu iranischen wird gegen
die bevölkerung dass die bezug auf das
recht hat sich zu verteidigen und was
auch mit wasser wir haben es auch in
deinem beitrag gesehen wie kann man sich
das vorstellen das liegt uns allen ja
sofern bewaffnet auf eine demonstration
zu gehen
wie kann man sich das vorstellen jetzt
müssen wir in getan was er und man muss
dafür natürlich eine bewilligung
einholen einen schein tragen
für das recht offen auf der straße
waffen zu tragen aber unter natürlich
sturmgewehre und weitere pistolen
jagdgewehre patronengürtel das sind alle
sehr martialisch aus das ist natürlich
schon eine eigene eigene art von amerika
die viele menschen in der aller welt
schockiert und eigentlich postamt
schockierend ist die tatsache dass eben
diese menschen teilweise glauben dass
sie das recht hätten
sich gegen die regierung zur wehr zu
setzen teilweise mit waffengewalt das
natürlich zu
so weit sind wir hier in leizig mäßigen
noch nicht die auch nicht in anderen
bundesstaaten wo es zu demonstrationen
gekommen ist aber es geht in der
bevölkerung und es wächst der druck auf
die gouverneure der bundesstaaten die
krone regeln zu lockern das alles steht
natürlich im totalen kontrast zu allen
gesundheitsexperten die dazu mahnen
langsam und behutsam hier vorzugehen
denn viele befürchten dass es zu einer
zweiten welle zu einem neuen ausbruch
kommen könnte herbert vielen herzlichen
dank so weit nach michigan